pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
face aux difficultés de la circulation
une recette
la savate c'est ainsi en effet que la
boxe française longtemps oubliés dans
les pages du dictionnaire revient au
goût du elle possède à paris son
sanctuaire hautement intellectuel ou
d'honorables gentlemen vienne renouer
avec les exercices chers amis leurs
larcins
ce qui nécessite on le comprend une
sérieuse mise en train préalable et
justifie la transformation de la salle
d'armes du club en une sorte d' annexe
de l'opéra
[Musique]
après quoi rien ne vaut une bonne
démonstration pour mettre dans
l'ambiance
la boxe française sport complet qui fait
appel aux jambes comme au bras requiert
souplesse et décision et s'il est aisé
de porter les coups bas
il faut une bonne détente pour porter
des coups au flanc
davantage encore pour les porter dans la
figure
[Musique]
dès lors il va de soi que de la théorie
à la pratique il reste encore un sérieux
pas à franchir les meilleures bonnes
volontés peuvent en être ébranlé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme quoi la boxe française que
pratiquer nos valeureuses aïeux n'est
pas un sport de dilettante
[Musique]
au dessus de la route nationale dont les
aménagements souterrains sont terminés
l'extension de l'aéroport d'orly se
poursuit l'aéroport qui demain sera
vaste comme le cinquième paris possède
déjà les deux plus grands hangars
d'europe
doté d'un toit de 50 mètres de voler en
porte à faux
vient d'inaugurer au centre de contrôle
régional le radar de surveillance
aérienne le plus puissant d'europe
[Applaudissements]
on connaît le principe lorsque les
impulsions d'énergie à haute fréquence
envoyé 400 fois par seconde rencontre un
obstacle
il se produit un écho et 7 et court bien
ce matériel est visuellement sur l'écran
du radar
[Musique]
avec le radar de paris et les futurs
radars de lyon de marseille et de
bordeaux
et grâce à des connexions de télévision
chaque centre régional pourra contrôler
la france entière
ainsi le centre d'orly dispose de moyens
de surveillance dont la précision et la
perfection sont à la mesure des
long-courriers à réaction
l'équipement anti tuberculeux de la
france s'est enrichie du sanatorium
rhône azur qui vient d'être inauguré à
briançon
en assumant sa réalisation les caisses
de sécurité sociale de lyon et de
marseille ont voulu en faire un modèle
du genre
ces installations techniques très
moderne explorations fonctionnelles
équipements radiologiques
[Musique]
laboratoire permettent de définir le
traitement le plus efficace
du contrôle de l'acuité auditive menacés
par certains antibiotiques jusqu'aux
salles d'opération ultra moderne
rien n'a été négligé
[Musique]
et à côté de l'indispensable rééducation
fonctionnelle des malades
on a fait place à leur éducation au
travail
[Musique]
on a tenu à ce qu'il puisse aussi trouvé
le plus grand confort pour le corps
comme pour l'esprit élément primordial
d'une guérison rapide
à 1350 mètres d'altitude face au massif
du pelvoux le sanatorium rhône azur est
le seul en france capable de traiter
toutes les formes de tuberculose les
malades y trouveront les conditions les
plus propices à leur établissement
largement aidé par un ensoleillement
exceptionnel de 300 jours par an
henri le navigateur mort voici cinq
cents ans est le héros du jour au
portugal à lisbonne en l'église de
hieronymus construite au xvième siècle
avec le produit des épices et des
diamants rapporté des indes
les chevaliers de mal le duc de bragance
et le petit prince l'ex roi d'italie
umberto et le chef du gouvernement
monsieur salazar ont ouvert la série des
cérémonies qui tout au long de l'année
magnifieront la gloire de celui qui fut
l'instigateur des grandes aventures
océane
le même jour une session de l'assemblée
nationale en présence du président de la
république devait être l'occasion
d'évoquer cette glorieuse époque peu
connu hors des frontières portugaises
l'histoire a retenu le nom de christophe
colomb ceux de barthélémy dias de vasco
de gama pourtant dès le début le 14e
siècle
depuis cette tour de belem qui commande
l'entrée du tage henri le navigateur
avait envoyé ces caravanes à la
découverte du monde
[Musique]
les inventeurs se sont donné rendez vous
à bruxelles et leur 9e salon s'avère
être une mine de trouvailles toutes plus
étonnantes les unes que les autres
tirer une photo en 15 secondes sans
chambre noire n'est plus ici un problème
pour personne
[Musique]
pas plus que ramé à l'envers sans perdre
de vue pour autant la vendre la barre on
y trouve le papier magique qui supprime
les fautes de frappe
le tuteur avec lequel plus une tête des
colliers ne fléchira le cric électrique
pour voitures et pour conducteurs
fatigués
[Musique]
et si le radar personnel en cas de
programme n'est pas suffisant voici
l'écran antichars on peut faire beaucoup
de choses avec des épingles même les
illustrations d'un livre c'est le cas du
docteur jivago les 200 illustrations
sont toutes nées d'un million d'épingler
enfoncé dans un écran d'un mètre carré
conçu par un peintre parisien alexandre
alexeyev le procédé vaut d'être dévoilée
les épingles font saillie d'un côté de
l'écran si on enfonce une sous un
éclairage particulier elle fait naître
en ressortant de l'autre côté une tâche
sombre en enfonçant plusieurs on obtient
d'un côté une figure clair de l'autre
une figure sombre identique
première opération au verso madame
alexeyev au moyen d'un rouleau enfonce
les épargnes au recto simultanément
apparaît donc une bande uniformément
sombre c'est sur cette bande ka
l'excellent ep tu vas travailler en
enfonçant certes n est pas
dispose pour cela d'un instrument de
touche de toute forme un anneau il lui
suffira de l'appuyer
d'une certaine façon et ce sera la lune
[Musique]
un autre à nos okan lure en épis de blé
et une à une
apparaîtront les branches d'un sapin
je
pour finir un rouleau parsemé de trous
et de bosses et c'est maintenant
l'apparition des flocons de neige
ainsi par le simple jeu de l'ombre
portée des épingles plus ou moins
enfoncé tout un tableau et n'est qu'un
coup de rouleau effacera mais auparavant
il aura été fixée sur une plaque
photographie là n'est pas limité le
procédé d'alexandre alexeyev par les
variations de la source lumineuse et en
appliquant le principe du dessin animé
il a pu aussi image par image donner la
vie à un monde merveilleux c'est ainsi
que sont nés voici 25 ans les
fantasmagories d'une nuit sur le mont
chauve un des classiques du dessin animé
orgueil de toutes les cinémathèques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]